("William Tell Overture")
- Way to go, sport.
Nice hustle, champ.
You do me.
("William Tell Overture")
- There it is, feel it, feel it.
That's right, that's the good burn.
That's the good burn, feel it.
Right in there.
("William Tell Overture")
- [Man in Glasses] Andrew,
what are you doing?
- Just studying you in my film room.
Fascinating.
("William Tell Overture")
- That's not how you spell restaurant.
- Here you go.
- Oh, lucky you, it's free
bobble head day at my desk.
- Nope.
- You'll cherish it forever.
("William Tell Overture")
Alright, let's get this meeting started.
(mug shattering)
- Don't worry kid, we can cover this up.
- Great news everybody,
we had our best month on record.
(applause and cheering)
- Best month ever.
("William Tell Overture")